[Music]
nasa's ingenuity helicopter could make
its second trip above mars as early as
thursday monday's historic first flight
came after years of work by nasa
engineers to overcome
unprecedented challenges jonathan
vigliotti has more on the flight and
what it could mean
for the future of space exploration
this is the video nasa engineers waited
more than
six years to see monday ingenuity
lifted off the dusty surface of mars the
helicopter's own camera
captured a stunning picture of its
shadow the flight was brief less than 40
seconds long
and at low altitude about 10 feet but it
was more than enough to make it the
first
earthly aircraft to ever fly on another
planet
we have done it this is the first time
i've been able to say we've done it
with mars sitting 178 million miles away
from earth
project manager mimiang and her team had
to wait more than
three hours until nasa's mars
reconnaissance orbiter
passed overhead and relayed the data
back to earth
altimeter data confirmed
that ingenuity has performed its first
flight
an incredible feat considering mars is
mostly carbon dioxide atmosphere
is only around one percent as thick as
earth's the equivalent of altitudes
three times higher than mount everest
when things work
it looks easy i would like to take this
opportunity to remind how difficult it
is to fly a rotor crop at mars
the team plans four more flights over
the next two weeks
the hope that future helicopters could
one day serve as scouts for rovers
and eventually astronauts on the red
planet
for cbs this morning jonathan bigliotti
los angeles
it's a little machine and it's only a 10
foot flight but mars is 180 million
miles
exactly it looks like a mosquito but to
make a mosquito fly 108
million miles away so exciting job well
done nasa we're excited